the world of elden ring is full of
interesting mysteries it's how the game
was designed and how from software
designs all of their games they use
environmental storytelling to have the
players and the community make theories
on what certain things mean and what
they connect to the lore of elden ring
was and still is being heavily
researched and theories are coming out
like wildfire from so many amazing
creators and enthusiasts of the game so
much so that it's overwhelming to put
all of that information together into a
somewhat understandable plot line while
the main aspects of the story are pretty
clear to understand the details of the
world that we'll talk about in this
video will definitely lead to more
questions than answers so let's take a
look at some interesting finds together
and we'll discuss in the comments what
we think they could mean some of these
finds are just interesting and really
have nothing to do with the story but
some of them could lead to connections
within the story if you have any
interesting finds that you'd like to
point out you can join our discord and
discuss it there you can message me on
twitter or instagram or again just
comment down below so let's get into it
the first thing i'd like to discuss are
the isolated towers most people have
found that when observed from the map or
from the sky the towers create a circle
when linked together but when looking at
the outside of each tower you'll notice
that the left side is sort of distorted
i originally thought that this distorted
side of the tower pointed toward pharam
azula but that doesn't seem to be
consistent with all of the towers there
also seems to be a missing tower located
near the capital city the lead up in
entrance through this area is almost
exactly similar to that of other divine
tower locations however that path
abruptly ends sort of like it was
scraped completely off of the hill this
could be the original location of the
isolated tower and from this tower
pharam azula can be seen out in the
distance it is known that pharah
missoula used to hover above limgrave
and stormville castle where missoula
then moved out to the far east maybe the
tornado ripped off the isolated tower
and then somehow placed it in the middle
of the sea on its way to its present
location or this could have been the
location of mykola's divine tower that
we currently don't know the location of
yet although what's more likely is that
mykola and melania share a divine tower
since they're twins just like morgot and
moog also regarding pharaoh missoula i
thought it was somewhat interesting that
the layout of pharamizula is the same
from a distance as it is when we are
actually there i've had a theory that
pharaoh missoula when we are sent there
is outside the present time of when we
are in the lands between throughout the
rest of the game even if that may or may
not be the case the layout is the same
not rendered very well obviously but we
can see the great bridge leading up to
malachite's boss room i've also been
spending a lot of time listening to
certain sound effects throughout the
game i've literally been running around
playing the game with only sound effects
turned all the way up with everything
else turned down the most interesting
sound i've heard so far is from the
elden beast which gives off a very
distinct bass boosted sound that gives
me vibes of interstellar space which
fits the theme of the boss perfectly
take a listen
now i'm sure this has already been seen
or mentioned somewhere out there but the
elden beast character model goes far
below the boss arena with a very long
tail that has some golden roots growing
off the end of it this is obviously for
when it leaps up into the air but i
found it interesting that they kept that
part of the model fully rendered at all
times small but weird find for this area
as well is if we move the camera far
above the arena we can see the platform
that we fight against ratagon on still
somewhat rendered in along with a fully
rendered summoning pool the door to the
er tree and a fog gate they likely have
to keep these assets rendered in if the
player does use the summoning pool to
fight with a friend as for the fog gate
and the door i have no idea why these
are here another interesting find about
melania is that she is more than likely
most definitely blind when we enter the
boss room before triggering the cutscene
we can see a really good look at how
badly her eyes have just been completely
taken over by the scarlet rot i'm not
entirely sure why it looks so much worse
here than it does in the cutscenes
probably because it's not fully rendered
because the player would never be able
to get in this position without the help
of mods like i'm doing here so they
probably just didn't need to render it
her blindness could explain why her
waterfowl dance is her just flirting
around randomly it's not like she's
panicking but it's like she doesn't know
our exact location so she flurries her
sword around seemingly at random to have
a better chance at hitting us and that
seems to work just fine for her most of
the time she's likely tracking us
through the rest of the fight based on
the sounds we make in the water and just
in the boss room all together next thing
i want to talk about are the cut scenes
for most boss fights in the game if you
didn't know the cutscenes are generated
within the game they position the
player's character model in certain
positions and based on the scene the
developers want it to show they'll move
the characters around to get the best
shot for the camera sometimes they'll
just remove the player's character model
altogether since they're just not in the
shot for that scene they'll also
sometimes move models in certain
positions floating above the ground just
to get a better shot they'll also change
the lighting around for what works
better within the frame of that shot i
find all this stuff really interesting
for some reason as it dives into the
critical thinking process of the
developers and what they were trying to
showcase for certain scenes and boss
fights they'll even blur the entire
surrounding area when the shot is close
up to a character model which gives a
sense of depth to the shot that would
otherwise look a bit strange without the
blurred background the melania boss
fight has a lot of cool examples of this
like i've been showing on screen now i
didn't notice this next find till
recently but you can see that surash
godfrey's lion companion is actually
biting down on godfrey's shoulder during
the first phase of the boss fight suraj
is meant to calm godfrey when he's
fighting so he doesn't abandon his elden
lord status to fight like the warrior he
truly is like he does in the second
phase so it's interesting to see this
calming effect is just the form of suraj
biting down on godfrey another small
note is that godfrey isn't actually
holding morgot in his arms until the cut
scene actually starts they probably
didn't think it relevant to do so since
he has his back turned to us and
wouldn't be in the view of the player
till the cutscene actually starts also
when we zoom in close on godfrey's eyes
we can see that they're faded out and to
me resembled the faded dead eyes of
godwin in the deep root depths we know
that godfrey's sight of grace was taken
away by queen merika and it's possible
his eyes used to have this golden hue
just like when we look into the eyes of
godric who is another descendant of the
golden lineage of godfrey himself and
while we're on the topic of eyes when we
look closely at gideon's armor set the
eyes throughout the set also have
similarities to that of godwin the armor
set has that same gray faded out hue to
that of godwin's eyes it's also known
that godwin's influence even with the
death of his soul his body is still
spreading throughout the lands between
we can see godwin's eyes in so many
different places and when we think of
gideon being the all-knowing it would
sort of make sense that he'd want eyes
all over the world to gain as much
knowledge as possible this is obviously
a bit of a stretch but nonetheless is
still an interesting theory last thing i
want to talk about today was an
interesting find found by a souls
creator
zolly the witch but in regards to radon
she found that when you look below the
boss arena when radon leaps into the sky
he plunges his horse leonard below the
sand you can actually see that leonard
tracks your location
under the sand so that radon's character
model knows where to crash down at the
start of his second phase this is
definitely one of the coolest finds i've
found in the game so far also when it
comes to radon i'm sure it's already
widely known that radon doesn't have
feet they've either fallen off from the
spread of the scarlet rot or scraped off
when he drags his feet through the sand
for what is likely thousands of years
but if we look a bit closer we can
definitely see a type of fungus
surrounding the legs that doesn't have
that red hue that is normally
representing the scarlet rot there's
also some type of webbing connection
with the fungus as well no idea what
this could be at this time but let me
know what you think and that goes for
everything we've discussed in this video
and again you can join our discord and
message me on twitter instagram if
there's certain interesting findings
that you've found and want to discuss
shout out to my patrons with the
continued support they get early access
to videos with absolutely no ads so if
you're interested in that check the
links down below also i've started a
second channel called agt golf where i
want to start making golf content i
haven't talked about this too much on
this channel but i used to be a
professional golfer and unfortunately
suffered nerve damage in my right wrist
i haven't played competitively in a few
years but my wrist feels great and
thanks to you guys i'm now in a position
to work from home and have a lot of time
to practice so if you guys are
interested in some different content
from myself go check out my golf channel
linked in the description i'll start
putting out some videos there whenever i
figure out the best way to do so
appreciate all of you guys very much
thanks for watching the video and i will
see you in the next one take care